consider the closed curve in the
xy-plane given by this expression here
find the coordinates of the two points
on the curve where the line tangent to
the curve is vertical so pause this
video and see if you could have a go at
it so I don't know what the exact shape
of this closed curve is but if I were to
draw a some type of a closed curve maybe
it looks something like this this isn't
the one that's right over here this one
also has two points where my tangent
line is vertical at one point would be
right over there
another point would be right over there
now how do we figure this out well what
we could do is use implicit
differentiation to find the derivative
of Y with respect to X and think about
the x and y values that would give us a
situation where that derivative is non
zero in the numerator and zero in the
denominator so let's do that so let's
just let me rewrite everything I have x
squared plus 2x plus y to the fourth
plus 4y is equal to five I want to take
the derivative with respect to X of both
sides of this equation I'm trying to
find an expression for the derivative of
Y with respect to X and so what am I
going to get this is going to be equal
to 2x plus 2 plus derivative of this
with respect to Y is 4y to the third and
then times the derivative of Y with
respect to X that's just straight out of
the chain rule plus derivative of this
with respect to Y is 4 times the
derivative of Y with respect to X once
again straight of the chain rule is
equal to what's I want to take the
derivative with respect to X here is
equal to zero and now we just have to
solve for dy/dx so there's a couple
things we could do we could take the 2x
plus two and subtract it from both sides
and we could also factor out a 4 dy/dx
out of this stuff right over here so
let's do that let's subtract the 2x plus
2 from both sides and factor out the 4
times dy/dx so we will get 4 times dy/dx
times y to the 3rd plus 1 is equal to is
equal to I subtracted this from both
sides
so I get negative - and actually let me
factor out a negative two so negative
two times X plus one and now I just have
to divide both sides by four times all
of this business and I am going to get
the derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to negative two times X plus one
divided by divided by four times y to
the third plus one and actually this can
be rewritten as being equal to negative
of X plus one divided by two times y to
the third plus one I just divided the
numerator in the denominator by two now
why is this useful well we could think
about what Y values because Y is the
only variable we have in the denominator
here would make the denominator equal
zero
and then find the corresponding X values
for those Y values by going to our
original equation well this is going to
be zero zero when y is equal to negative
one so when y is equal to negative one
let's figure out what X is and to do
that we just have to substitute y equals
negative 1 back in our original equation
and then solve for x so let's do that
let me clear this out since I need that
real estate so if we go back and we
substitute y equals negative 1 up here
we're going to get x squared plus 2x
plus 1 plus 1 minus 4 is equal to 5 this
is going to be negative 3 subtract 5
from both sides you get x squared plus
2x minus 8 is equal to 0 this is just
simple factoring so it's going to be X
plus 4 times X minus 2 what two numbers
when I take their product I get negative
8 4 negative 2 when I add 4 negative 2 I
get a positive 2 there is equal to 0 so
X is equal to negative 4 or X is equal
to positive 2 when y is equal to
negative 1 so to answer their question
find the coordinates of the two points
on the curve where the line tangent to
the curve is vertical well the answer
here would be get a little bit of a
drumroll it would be the points x equals
negative 4 and Y is equal to negative 1
and
x equals two and y is equal to negative
one and we're done